He went that way.
North-West 100 meters.
No weapon.
Easy kill.
Car!
No, plane.
Watch for the drop.
I could use a bigger gun.
Oh shit. That's real close.
Let's get it.
That's a death trap.
We haven't seen anyone out here for hours.
We're probably the only ones left.
I mean the game's still going, right?
Then there's other people left.
Yeah, cause they're watching the crate!
Look, I don't even have a gun.
You have a freaking frying pan!
If we don't get what's in that crate
we're getting killed by the guys who do.
What do you think we get if we win?
Probably a million dollars, or something.
Be great.
You know what would be great? Not dying.
How about not dying, and a million bucks?
You cross that field, you're going to get shot!
Look, just crawl. No one will see you.
I can see you guys.
If somebody shoots at us
shoot at them.
Eh, I can do that. Alright.
How do you open it?
Surprise mother fucker!
You forgot to rack it, didn't you?
Guys.
Grena-
I got this, from this pack.
It should help take the edge off.
Is it over?
Niko killed a guy with a frying pan.
No shit.
Wha-What?
You guys forgot the main weapon?
Wren. Chill, chill, chill.
Sam's not happy about it.
So I don't know where that f**king scope is.
They forgot a radio so I have no idea what's going on over there right now.
The lady, she's gone by probably twelve times now.